and we've been looking ahead of sunday's
german election that we'll see the end
of angela merkel's 16 years in power at
the country's green credentials the
climate has featured heavily in the
election campaign but is germany as
green as it would like to think simon
and vicky thank you so much for joining
us um samuel let's start with you just
how green is germany
uh germany's not that green in that
about a quarter of its electricity is
coming from coal-fired power stations
very polluting and it's coming from
the worst kind of coal lignite
and it doesn't have a phase-out until
2038
and to put that in context
uh xi jinping the chinese leader
announced at the un
that it would phase out
all overseas financing of coal-fired
power stations and struck out 47
coal-fired power stations with that one
sentence
and that's about the same carbon
emission stopped as germany's emitting
with its coal-fired power stations today
and on cars it doesn't have any phase
out date
for phase it for ending the sale of new
petrol and diesel cars
and
without that
and with the coal
uh the the supreme court
in uh in germany
said that germany's climate policies
were
unconstitutional because young people
wouldn't have a good life
in the future because
these policies were not committed that
were not
consistent with
the paris agreement
it's interesting isn't it a recent poll
found that 65 of germans are in favor of
stricter measures to fight climate
change vicky what do you think it's
interesting that the greens are in third
place you'd think
with that sort of public support they'd
be right up there in first wouldn't you
you would indeed but of course we must
remember that germany is a major
manufacturing country uh has a much
larger percentage of manufacturing is
gdp than is the case in the uk so
phasing out all that there's lots of
energy-intensive sectors there which we
find it difficult to move to
uh you know
using
cleaner energy
uh because basically not much cleaner
energy is necessarily supplied and what
is going on right now of course is that
germany is relying heavily on gas that
comes out of uh russia it has said it's
going to stop any new nuclear and of
course that's been phased out so it's
limited in terms of what you can
actually do but i think on the positive
side
we need to bear in mind that it's very
much part of the bush right now that the
eu is making in terms of clean green
bonds
raising money that can be spent in
more energy efficient
uh production and of course it's also
moving way ahead of other countries in
battery production so there is still a
lot that is happening the question is
how fast can they
move to meet what the population was but
as you say interestingly the greens are
not doing
uh as well as perhaps you would have
expected which suggested me that uh the
germans still value quite a lot of what
is being produced right now by the by
the industry there that existed present
um simon let's go back to this court
ruling that you mentioned april 2021 a
court ruled that germany's climate
change laws are insufficient again it
looks like all the right noises are
being made angela merkel herself was a
supporter of climate protection measures
do you think we are going to see a
change after these elections that
change will actually take place and it
won't just be talk
well i think it's it's uh it's going to
be difficult to say and that's because
the german
electoral system is is different from
the uk and they will have a coalition
um but if it's a coalition between some
of the left parties and the green party
then that probably gives the greatest
chance of really shifting policies
towards a much greener agenda whether
that's green homes electric vehicles and
getting uh their
electricity supply onto renewables as
fast as possible